you've actually been in a quite a few
music videos as well so I have to ask
you like how did you end up this is
amazing you were in blame it with Jamie
Foxx and T-Pain How did that what was
that like was there did they just call
you I have no idea Kelly okay I'm like I
don't know how I got it this is
incredible if Jamie Foxx you know he's
like a I love Jamie he's so great and he
just called me up and he was like I
clearly was at a loss of finding people
I was like probably last I was like what
I mean Jill and all G's not far down but
it's definitely the end of the G's and
he had gotten all through ABCDEF oh my
God of all Hollywood people and he got
there well yeah because clearly because
Ron Howard's in it also H and gr
Whitaker it was like that's what I'm
saying yeah
like how do you get so it's Ron Howard
me uh Jamie Foxx and Forest Whitaker in
a car in a Hype Williams directed video
and it starts off and like he didn't
want me to drive this Bentley and like
somehow I thought I was gonna wear this
hat and it was like cool looking and and
and and I just like again he's like oh
James like you drive you drive and I was
like okay I drive and it was in slo-mo
and and the beginning of the video
starts with us but four of us rolling up
to a club like like because how y'all
would do yeah
[Laughter]
right I love it and uh and and it was in
slow-mo but I had to hit a mark and
there were like these sandbags for the
car to hit so I hit the mark right for
the camera yeah and uh I just was not
familiar with the car and every time I
roll up in slow-mo the the car would hit
the sandbag and we would all sort of
jolt forward so if you slow mo so if you
see the video it's like us like I'm just
like trying to be hard and I'm just like
roll up like this and it starts and it's
just all of us going
oh
like right before it's just it was great
it was great it was actually honestly
because what's funny is when they do the
slow-mo usually they play the track
really fast yeah so that's true so
they're playing in a music video and
it's it's they play the trick track like
extra fast so especially when you're
doing the lyrics you have to be like
really fast and it's and then it slows
it down this was the intro so it wasn't
even that you can't even give me that I
just couldn't drive the car
all right that's amazing
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody